Hi. I'm Peter Norvig. I'll be your instructor for CS212, Design of Computer Programs.
I'm assuming that you have some background.
You took CS101 or the equivalent elsewhere,
so you understand the basics of statements, expressions, and data types
in Python or some other language.
Now, what this class will be about is the design process:
how to take what you already know and put them together in order to solve a problem.
We'll talk about some of the attributes of good programs--
correctness, efficiency, generality and so on--
and we'll give you a process for thinking about design:
how to go from the uncertain stage of not knowing what the problem really is
and working your way all the way through to a good solution.
We'll also give you a set of tools that you can use along the way.
I had a lot of fun choosing the examples for this class and working them out,
and I think you'll have a lot of fun too,
and when you're done, you'll have a real sense of accomplishment.
So I hope to see you in class.